- Hello, everyone.
Welcome to our daily homeroom,
for those of you all,
if this is the first
time you're joining us,
this is a livestream we're
doing on a daily basis.
The catalyst was the school closures
that are now around the world,
over 1.6 billion students
around the world,
who normally would be attending school,
are no longer doing that,
at least for the time being.
And what we see our
responsibility as a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing a free
world-class education
for anyone, anywhere,
it's always been in service to teachers,
to parents, to students,
to make sure that folks
can have the best possible
learning experience.
And we realize that
especially in this time
of school closures, it's
our duty to step up,
and figure out how we can support you,
the parents, the students,
the teachers out there,
how we can support school districts.
I know we're gonna have a really
robust conversation about that today.
And, I do want to remind everyone,
we are a not-for-profit organization,
and we are able to do what we do
because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in the position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I want to give a special thanks
to several corporate partners
who recently stepped up
to support these efforts
to keep Khan Academy going
so that we can keep everyone learning.
Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, and Novartis.
If any of your corporations
are thinking about it,
they should contact us as well.
We were running at a deficit
even before this crisis hit
and now our costs have
gone up dramatically
to support our servers, which
are now 2-1/2, 3X normal load,
and all the other programs that we would
like to support parents,
teachers, and students with.
And so our deficits are even larger.
So if you can, please support us.
So with that, I'd like
to introduce our guest,
Dr. Jesus Jara, who is the Superintendent
at Clark County School District.
They are the fourth or fifth largest
school district in America.
This is Greater Las
Vegas, for those of y'all
who might not be as
familiar with Clark County.
And this is, I'm excited
about this conversation.
We've partnered with Dr. Jara,
actually at Clark County,
and in his previous world when
he was working in Orlando.
But Dr. Jara, maybe a good place to start,
how are you and your
family doing, first of all?
Before we get into the...
- Yeah, first before we get into the work,
well, first of all, Sal,
I just want to thank you
for giving me the opportunity
to share a little bit.
We're all safe and sound at home.
I've got two college kids
that have been working online
and doing some of the online
learning at both institutions.
So we're just staying home,
staying home for Nevada
as our Governor has continued
to remind our folks.
And learning a new
world of education here,
and also administrating
the administration,
really, and helping our
hardworking teachers
and principals from our computers.
So it's been a little bit of a challenge
in moving to this direction,
but we're doing well.
Thank you.
- And just going into that a little bit,
I've been curious as, over the last,
everyone's been fighting their own crises
over the past four or five weeks,
but I'd love to hear it
from your perspective,
as a superintendent of a
large complex school district,
when did it get on your radar that
something like this might happen?
And as best as you can,
kind of play it out?
When did it become clear
it was going to happen,
how did you scenario plan,
what are you trying to optimize for now?
- Yeah, when it started,
we had early conversation,
I was having a discussion
with some of our partners
here on the strip and they said, hey,
what are you guys doing
for the coronavirus?
And I immediately brought my team in,
and that was in late
February, to start putting in
and rolling out our emergency
management plan in place.
As a school system we
always are dealing with
a lot of different issues,
and I recall the day I was,
March 4th, I was up in
Carson City and Reno
for a discussion, a
superintendent meeting,
and the County Commission Chair called
and immediately we had our first case.
And I can tell you, playing
out from that first case
from here in Las Vegas
to some of the issues
that just evolved rather
quickly in a matter of hours,
to start just really
calming down the community
and learning and understanding
what that meant for children,
'cause obviously the
first case was an adult,
but then it's the quarantine
and getting the guidance
from the CDC and then
really, from the first week,
through the first week
and a half it's just,
from learning from the experts,
learning from our medical
experts on processes,
and putting and enacting our plan
that it seems like it's
been six, seven months,
where we're only a month,
a month and a week in,
and really preparing for what
happens for school closure,
and everything as a superintendent
just evolved, and calling and working with
some of the long-standing superintendents
that have been in this
business to try to understand.
But this is unlike any other,
unlike any other emergency.
As you mentioned, I came from Florida,
and when we first started, and really
closing schools for hurricanes, right,
but there's always that endpoint,
and how do you start
your continuity program?
This is different, this is so different
than preparing for a hurricane
or any other disaster.
This has just been moving and learning
in unchartered waters.
But then the impact that I
see here, that I see unlike
any other place that I've
been at, it's just really
the impact, because our
kids and our families,
and then as we shut down, as the Governor,
the leadership from the
Governor's office to shut down
the entire state in
education, all our facilities,
then within two days, all the
businesses have shut down.
So now, it's how do we start going through
all of that, providing the essentials?
Our kids, 68% of our children
are on free and reduced lunch,
so it was preparing for how are we going
to feed our kids and our families?
So it just, just to
backpedal, moving to, again,
the essentials, the safety
first, getting them home,
then feeding them, and then start moving
into our distance learning
education program.
Like I said, it's been something that,
it's taken us a week or two to
start getting in the groove,
but then it always continues to evolve
and change and continue to learn
and make sure that our kids are engaged.
- That's super useful.
And for those of you all listening,
if you're on Facebook or YouTube,
you can put questions
in the message boards.
We have team members
who are looking at them,
and I'll try to surface those to Dr. Jara.
This is a great opportunity
to ask questions
of a superintendent who's running
a very large complex school district.
If you're pretty much
in any other urban area,
the questions that you'd
ask your superintendent
are just as applicable as the
stuff that Dr. Jara is facing.
But Dr. Jara, talk a little bit about,
more about that, because I think a lot of,
for lack of a better word, civilians,
imagine, okay, the school
district, they teach some stuff,
maybe you have to go online a little bit,
but there's all these
other social services
that the school district
provides around lunches.
There's also questions of
equity around internet access.
How did that play out
with you and your team,
especially that first weekend, I remember,
when it started to become clear
that schools were going to have to close?
- Yeah, we started
preparing for that closure,
what is that closure gonna look like,
and then the team started putting together
learning opportunities, so
we can have paper, pencil,
when you look at the poverty level,
we are the fifth largest
district, we have 320,000 kids.
68% of them are free and reduced lunch.
That means there's that level of poverty.
And we did not have a
digital one-to-one device
as a school system and as a state,
and so we had the
inequities there as well.
So it was whatever learning opportunities
that we were gonna put out
there on the paper, pencil,
we're also gonna give our kids access.
So one of the things that
we originally started with,
it was really the main
essentials, 'cause as I mentioned,
our food insecurity is also very high,
so bringing in our food
department, our food service.
We started with 15 sites
across our school system,
to feed our community, to
feed our children, to come in,
and at the same time as we're
doing that, then we also
put out our learning opportunities,
not only on the website,
but then we started printing paper copies.
So then you were getting a meal,
and it was just watching
and seeing our kids.
And I visited so many of them.
Our parents were there, and
our families, and our kids,
and one of the things that was
very popular for the parents
was the learning
opportunities, the homework,
the homework packets, not
so popular for our kids,
but it was really a way
to keep them engaged,
but their focus was again the
safety and the mental health.
We moved into, from 15, very rapidly,
because we saw the gaps
across our 360 schools,
we moved, now we currently
have 38 different feeding sites
where we continue to
have the packets there.
And then we started rolling
out our one-to-one devices,
our Chromebooks that we had in inventory,
and then our first priority
was our high school seniors.
We wanted to make sure that
our high school seniors,
we were not going to have them suffer
their graduation and their opportunities.
So we started deploying Chromebooks,
we're a Chromebook school system,
so we started deploying for
our high school seniors,
and then our credit-bearing
high school students,
for those that did not have devices.
Also a big gap there,
we had about 64% of our,
when we look at our
inventory, 64% of our students
who had devices, the other ones did not.
So immediately reallocated dollars
from the federal government
to purchase devices.
So we purchased 46,000 devices that are
just coming in now, moving rather quickly.
Then we reached out to
our community partners,
Cox Communication to offer the Wi-Fi.
Then we bought some, moving
rather swiftly, in purchasing
the hot spots as well, so
we can distribute that.
Again, that is all student-driven.
Our principals are doing a phenomenal job
of really working with our teachers.
And then our teachers are now starting to,
for those kids that have the opportunity
for the learning
opportunities, for the teachers
to start connecting
with our students online
through normal, their Google
Hangout and the Google Meetup
and some of those platforms
that we have available.
And then in some cases, even phone calls,
because again, the digital
divide for us was great.
But I can tell you, this
community has stepped up
significantly to provide
opportunities for our students.
So those were some of the most immediate,
and now we are monitoring,
as a matter of fact,
as you mentioned, we're great partners.
Our assessment, now we're having
deep conversations internally,
is what we do with,
now that we have everything,
I think, settled,
when we look at our distribution
and our instruction,
principals are now doing
virtual faculty meetings.
So a lot of these things that
we're getting into a groove,
even, we're in Spring Break
this week, which is good,
it's letting us catch our
breath, to then kick-start.
So now we're looking at, okay,
what are we gonna do now
for the next six weeks?
We don't know whether we're
gonna come back to school.
It's now providing
professional development
for professional learning
for our teachers,
for our administrators, so
when our kids come back,
our children come back to
school, is how do we get
to close out the year, and
then really looking at the data
to start addressing some
of the gaps, and I know
that we're big partners
with you, with Khan Academy,
and MAP Accelerator, and
also our NWEA partner.
So we're looking at how we do that now
to get ready to start.
You'll be proud, I'll tell
you, out of our numbers
in 3 through 8th, the number
I received this morning.
out of 165,000 students
at that grade level,
144,337 have been on MAP Accelerator
at least doing some of
that individual support
and really building up from what they had
aligned to their RIT score on MAP Growth.
So we're really, at least, excited to see
that there's some engagement at home,
and I told the team, we need
to continue to push that out.
It's not replacing the teacher,
but in these times, it's
giving us an opportunity
for some engagement in the classroom
and in the online classroom
at school and at home.
- Wow, that's incredible
what y'all are doing.
I don't think people fully appreciate
some of what you just said,
I just want to underline it.
You're thinking about feeding
hundreds of thousands of kids,
and then you deploying
internet access with devices
to sounds like tens of
thousands of households
in a matter of days, just
that is a major challenge.
But from the way you're describing,
that's kind of the
baseline, and then from that
you can build on top of that virtually.
And for those of you who aren't familiar
with what Dr. Jara is referring
to, this MAP Accelerator,
this is a partnership
we've done with the NWEA,
which is they provide the
MAP Growth Assessment,
where that assessment
now acts as a diagnostic,
as a placement for work on Khan Academy.
And Clark County is actually
one of the first districts
that we've partnered with around this.
We did a pilot this past year,
where Dr. Jara can see a
dashboard of what's going on,
how the kids are using MAP Accelerator.
I'm really heartened by those numbers.
And this is an interesting idea
because this notion of online learning,
we've obviously been talking
about the value of it
to let students learn at their own pace,
remediate gaps, et cetera,
before this crisis,
but it is interesting how it's evolved,
that it's something you could
lean on maybe a little heavier
when we're in a crisis
situation like this.
I am getting a lot of questions here.
Let's see, from YouTube, Craig Yen asks,
how are you supporting your
teachers with distant learning?
- Yeah, that's a great question,
and that's one of the things that we,
again, moving quickly,
into, in a week or so,
into a digital learning
platform for teachers,
and that's one of the things that
I just had a great
conversation this morning
with the team, is to now, continue
to support our teachers and
what does that look like?
So we're putting together a learning plan
for the next six weeks
and then for the summer.
We haven't done that in the
past as an entire system,
So it's something that
now, in conversations with
the Department of Education
here in the state of Nevada,
is we're gonna put together
some of our experts
across the state and start providing,
using another platform canvas,
to then provide some content for teachers.
And then also, looking at
some of these model lessons
as well, one of the things that
we're gonna start requesting
from our teachers is to start
sharing some of their lessons
so then we could then put
them on a platform for others.
At the school level, our
principals have done a great job
in really doing some PLCs, it's
all online, doing some PLC--
- [Sal] What does PLC stand for?
- Yep, professional learning communities
within their grade level and specific
to the schools, led by the administrators
or their content experts at the school.
So that's happening at
individualized school level.
And then obviously, for providing
support for the teachers
as well during their
weekly faculty meeting.
One of the other aspects that we're now,
as we're looking at, is the
analyzing the use of data.
So we're gonna start taking that time
to do that now as we're
closing out the year.
- And I have two related
questions, I'll combine them.
One from Facebook, Rebecca Nelson says,
do you foresee Clark County
embracing distance learning
for next school year, even if
the kids are able to return
to school, maybe modify
that as online learning
or some permutation, how
is the distance learning
changing the minds of educators?
And then related to that, Scott
Yang is asking on Facebook,
Dr. Jara, do you think
school can resume normally?
How do you think school will resume?
- Yeah, those are two great questions.
And that's what we've been,
we're challenging ourselves,
'cause we're thinking our
kids are gonna come back,
they're gonna enjoy this
new way of learning.
So I've challenged the
team as we move forward
to look at how are we going
to capitalize on where we are,
to provide opportunities
for distance learning?
So it's a conversation we're having.
I think as a district, it's stretched us,
our mindset, to then start moving forward
to provide different opportunities.
So do I predict it's going
to be a lot different?
I believe it is, and we're
going to have to evolve
and move quickly to be
able to get to that.
So it's gonna be different
and maybe more project-based.
And these are the conversations
that we're having now as
a team for the next year.
- And are there conversations happening,
or is it just too far ahead,
are people talking about
what if the virus picks
back up in the Fall,
or we loosen social distancing
and it picks back up?
How are y'all thinking about that?
Or is that just too far out right now?
- Well, Sal, this is why I love you.
You push me to think all the time.
We were thinking that we
may come back to school,
when we come back to school in August,
when we do that, we weren't
thinking about having to come back.
It's a good question to ask.
We were thinking that once
we come back when it's safe,
we'll just start over, it's
just gonna be different
and innovative, and I
think that's where we are.
But we'll just, at least
now, as I say to the team,
we know how to shut down a school district
rather quickly, we can start it back up.
But not yet, not yet as to coming back
and having to close again
because of the virus.
- Yeah, and I can't imagine the complexity
you have to deal with,
on a day-to-day basis,
much less through a process like this.
So you touched on it a little bit,
but there's two questions,
and this is a question
I've been getting a lot too,
and I am curious to get in more depth.
From YouTube user name July is asking,
how can you make sure that all kids
in your district have a
chance to learn online?
Do they have necessary equipment
like laptops, tablets, or internet?
And then from YouTube
Sixtus106 asks, Dr. Jara,
what are you doing to support
kids who don't have internet?
You mentioned a little bit
this roll out of Chromebooks,
you got more Chromebooks or
devices, you're trying to,
where are we, do all of
your kids now have access,
or are there still a subset that don't,
and how are you handling that?
- So our first week, when we
took attendance our first week,
which was three weeks ago,
we have 21, we were still
looking for, back then,
March 23rd through the 27th,
we were missing 21% of our students
that we had not been able to contact.
So now we're putting our social services,
we're putting our social workers,
we're putting call-outs
into the community.
If you have not heard from
us, at least back then,
is that you need to contact
the school and then continue
that conversation as we
continue to take attendance.
There is still the huge
digital divide that we have,
and we started, we have
our Public Ed Foundation
as well that has in our
community, very giving community,
that has started a campaign
to raise money for us,
not only for the device,
but for the hot spots,
but also for the professional
learning for the students,
for the parents, and for our teachers.
So it's a work in progress
to be quite candid with you.
- And related to that, we
have a bunch of questions
about the remainder of the
year, Facebook, Yolanda Brinez,
Facebook, Denise Puckett, on
YouTube, Liana Garcia Crespo,
they're all asking some version of,
is it for sure that schools are gonna
be remained closed through
the end of the year?
And then a related question
from Facebook, Tammy Harveston
is asking, will graduations
be canceled or postponed?
- So we're waiting.
When the Governor closed the schools,
it was it'll be depending, if
we open, it'll be depending on
the State chief health officer
to make that determination.
We've seen others across the country
that have made the
decisions not to reopen.
So it's a wait-and-see, so we
don't have that information.
I've asked for at least
a week lead time for us
to be able to reopen, it
just depends on where we are.
As a matter of fact, having conversations
this morning with the
team and I'm calling in,
next Wednesday, I will
be meeting, virtually,
with all our senior class
presidents from our schools,
we've got 49 high schools, to get ideas,
'cause we have some ideas
about how we do graduation.
Graduation is in May,
I don't foresee that,
because our partner at University
of Nevada Las Vegas here,
UNLV, is where we host,
and they're closed,
and they've canceled their
graduations or postponed them.
So we don't have the facility.
So we're gonna call out our seniors, I am,
to talk to them and get
some ideas from them,
'cause my greatest idea is not,
I'm not at their appropriate age group,
so I'm gonna get some of their
ideas to see how we do this.
- Yeah, and what about credit generally?
Is it still kind of a work-in-progress,
things like grades, is there a way that,
you don't have a point
of view on that yet?
- We do, the State just
released some guidance,
and working with all superintendents,
so we're working together.
We are going to our third marking period.
We opened up, which was right at close,
as soon as we were finishing
and we ended up closing school.
So we've opened up the
third marking period
for all our high schools and
our schools for credit-bearing
and across-the-board
secondary schools as well,
for students to make up any assignments
that they missed or wanted
to redo, so that's available.
And now we're having the conversations
about what we do for the
fourth marking period
and graduation requirements,
the State has left it up to us.
So next week we'll be meeting with
our senior high school
principals, and put some of those
requirements out for
our high school seniors.
And then also having conversations
with our higher Ed partners,
because I didn't want
our students because of this,
because of this pandemic,
to be penalized for GPA and
scholarship opportunities.
So we're looking and
we're always gonna side
on the side of the students,
and it's not their fault,
and it's something that we need
to find ways to address and help them.
- Yeah, and related to
everything we're talking about,
really, from YouTube,
Oshitosh Tiwari is asking,
how do you think the education
curriculum and syllabus will,
I think he's saying,
catch up, after COVID-19?
He's referring to this issue of,
normally you have a summer
slide, three months,
of not only going to
school, but potentially
forgetting or lost, now
you have five months.
We've seen some data that that might lead,
if kids aren't engaged
over that five months,
to as much as a year of lost learning.
So kids are gonna come at
the beginning of the year
with even bigger gaps, bigger variation,
are y'all, what's your thinking there?
- Yeah, that's a great
question and great comment.
I know that data was released,
NWEA released their data this morning
on their COVID-19 slide,
which is startling.
I've been on the phone, I
was with them on the phone
yesterday and last week with
Chris Minnich and his team.
One of the things that we're looking at
is to prepare for the restart and using
some of the federal stimulus
dollars that are coming in,
which is going to be very helpful.
Is it gonna be, so the team is looking at
the standards that we've
missed in this marking period,
so then how do we embed
them in the first semester?
Is it extending the day, it's
opportunities in the summer?
So we'll have a plan in
place in the coming week
on what we're going to be
able to do for our students
to catch them up because
it really is startling.
And when the data, when I looked at it,
and the pushback, not a
pushback, I think it was really,
when I looked at the data on
the average student from NWEA,
and I think the equity
gaps, and that's what
keeps me up at night,
because I think when you look
at the equity caps for our
children living in poverty,
our English language learners,
I think it's gonna be a
greater slide for them.
- Yeah. I just want you
to know, you're getting
a lot of very positive feedback
from several folks on
YouTube, on Facebook.
On Facebook, Shelly Fox
said, I love that you are
reaching out to seniors
for input and ideas.
Thank you for your leadership.
And then from YouTube,
BeautifulBecks wrote,
I think it's amazing how he's getting
student input for the seniors,
I hope my school does that.
So a lot of kudos there, Dr. Jara.
- Well thank you.
- And so there's another question here,
let me see if I can find it again,
it was about, it sounds like a parent,
there you go, from YouTube, Jen Mills,
and this is a question
I've been getting a lot,
although I have very
little expertise here,
how are you handling special education?
My son is autistic and our
district is not organized.
How are y'all thinking about that?
- Well, just to defend of the
district, I think there was
a lot of different
information coming to us early
from the U.S. Department of
Education, and it was just
really moving very, very
swiftly and changing.
So my team did a great job in working with
the Council of Great City Schools.
We put a document
together and it's really,
we're using the virtual world, obviously,
'cause, as we said, we
have a stay at home order,
so our special education educators
are reaching out through,
whether they have
Google Meets or whether
it's video conferencing,
of if not, there's no
technology, is a phone call,
video conferencing, to
provide the services.
I'll be honest, some of
the bigger challenges
that we're seeing is when we have,
we can do the support
there from our teachers
and our support staff that helps our kids,
one of the biggest challenges
that we're seeing is when we have
the occupational therapy
and the physical therapy
and we have to put our
hands on our students,
so that's one of the things
that we're being challenged.
So I want to, really,
for the school system,
wherever you are, it's
just been a moving target
and a challenge for us as well.
- Yeah, I can imagine.
So there's so many questions.
We're gonna have to
have you on again soon.
But maybe to close out,
there's a lot of doom and gloom
out in the world today, and a
lot of unanswered questions.
But you kind of hinted at
maybe there's silver linings,
that as we go through this
very suboptimal situation,
there might be things that we come out
maybe better for, or different at least.
Curious to get your
thoughts, what's your message
for any parents and teachers
and students listening
from Clark County, or as a proxy
for other peoples' superintendents,
what would you like to tell them?
- Well, just be patient,
which is a message
I've shared with our
communities, Sal and everyone,
is just be patient, this
is unprecedented times.
We don't know, and we're
gonna make mistakes.
It's hard, as I'll tell you,
as I do and hope and I know,
my colleague superintendents,
they're gonna make
the best decisions that they
think is the right decision
on behalf of their families and students.
So just be a little
patient, it's hard work.
As I see the future, I think
this is gonna force us to say,
you know, education is
gonna look different.
What different, what that
looks like, I don't know.
Our teachers, I'll tell you,
are hardworking teachers,
and I think our teachers, our educators,
have jumped right in, and
on behalf of our kids,
trying to do the best they can.
So looking forward to the
future and what that looks like,
we don't know what that
is, but it'll be exciting
for our kids, that's the
silver lining as I see it.
- Yeah, well, Dr. Jara, as always,
it's great to talk to you,
it's an honor to have y'all
as one of our close
partners at Khan Academy.
And stay safe and healthy, and
keep doing your great work.
- I will, thank you, Sal, I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
- Thank you.
Well, everyone, I thought that was
a super valuable update from Dr. Jara.
I just want to thank all
of y'all for joining.
We hope to continue to do this
throughout the closures
and maybe beyond, everyday.
Keep your questions coming.
And I'll just give another
reminder, we are not-for-profit.
If you're in a position to
do so, please think about
donating to Khan Academy, there is a URL
someplace on this screen,
khanacademy.org/donate.
And I'll also say, just speaking
as one human being to another,
whenever I meet folks like Dr. Jara.
and we had David Coleman
on a couple of days ago,
and Bill Gates a couple
of days before that,
you just see how a lot of folks are
stepping up and doing what they can.
As hard as this situation
is, I've been seeing
a lot of kind of the
best of humanity step up,
and we're all going through this together.
And it's great to be able to
connect with y'all in this way,
and hopefully it's making you feel
a little less socially distanced.
It's definitely helping me with that.
And so with that, I will
see y'all all tomorrow.